in this world a lot everyone wants to
know
in business and what you're doing and um
it's i think it's it's very interesting
when you go through things
and um people feel like they are like
kind of owed an explanation
but i understand i understand joey king
is opening up about working with her
ex jacob elordie in netflix's
the kissing booth too in the rom-com the
21-year-old
brings back her role as elle evans while
her real-life ex
jacob returns as noah flynn i miss you
jerk
i miss you more joey covers the
september issue of cosmopolitan
and says she wasn't about to let her
personal life
get in the way of her job quote no one's
thinking to themselves
that was easy because it wasn't the
actress added that she knows fans will
analyze
every moment and every detail of the
film
but she's not stressing quote let them
but at the end of the day
i was just thrilled to be l evans again
and then she doubled down on the
professional not gonna let an
x get in the way of the job mentality
quote l evans needs her noah flynn
and whatever that means for my personal
life i'll do anything to make sure the
story of my character who i care about
so much is complete yes queen
i am here for that when et caught up
with joey and jacob in july
they both talked about the downside to
dating in the public eye
stephen the fact that somebody would
could be someone that you don't know
knows your name is quite like
disembodying
but then eventually i think i just for
me personally i'm just
it's got nothing to do with me you know
it's like imagine
the store around the corner from where
you are now and whatever
people are talking about it's not your
business it's kind of how it feels it's
like
unfortunately just has my name involved
in it but it just
it literally has nothing to do with me
it just doesn't affect the trajectory of
my life so i just kind of ignore it you
know
i've you know publicly gone through some
things privately gone through some
things it's all about
finding your balance finding you know
what makes you comfortable
and um it can be it can be brutal but
you know also happy endings do come
to those who are you know patient
and joey may just have found that happy
ending
michael is a smack dating rumors have
been swirling around joey and
another kissing booth to co-star taylor
zakar perez
the speculation revved up earlier this
month when they went on a getaway
together
and with a few others and taylor shared
a few pics of the vacay on instagram
including some cozy shots of them in
their pajamas
and swimming under a waterfall oh
and he also left a super flirty comment
on
this bikini pic joey posted in honor of
her birthday
we know our what our relationship is
like we love each other dearly
but on monday the actor appeared on
barstool sports's
chicks in the office podcast and said
the two are just quote
quarantine buddies it's been interesting
how everyone is
trying to make something out of it but
it's fine it's
you know it's like hey i would love to
be dating joey king like
she's dope mm-hmm you heard that right
he said he would love to be dating joey
you know like i'm a huge proponent of
like dating your
your friends and someone that you know
and that you trust
and because like that's where it all
starts right it's like that that trust
like
for me intimacy um
like like non-sexual intimacy is like so
much more important to me
first and when et spoke to taylor
earlier this month
he shared that they cooked dinner for
each other while filming the movie
together in south africa
but he denied that he and joey are a
thing
we just kind of hit it off we just
became kind of like the best of friends
i love her i love her dearly i do
anything for her
we're not dating i'll end it with that